mother had nothing but
time endless time at first it was
madness
and enlightenment and as i watched the
life of time in all its
fleeting terrible light oh my god
welcome back to new rock stars rick and
morty season five episode one
just raced through over a dozen stories
in a rapidly unfolding narnia pocket
dimension
in the span of time that rick dined with
the two sexy mr nimbus and morty missed
yet another shot
with jessica by turning her into a time
cod we
are forgoing the more family-friendly
versions of this question that we ask on
inside marvel instead just asks
what what this is rick's playing
our rick and morty after show where we
overthink rick and morty because that is
the only true way to consume
it uh my easter egg breakdown will be uh
coming out tomorrow
of all the details that you missed here
i am with rick and morty superfan
co-survivor of fitness origins and
aggressive nintendo 69 user tommy
bechtold
that's right you should try wave race on
that thing it is insane
you keep trying to push me on the wave
race on nintendo 69.
i'm not gonna do it welcome to wave race
that's my impression of that guys you
did it uh
it's so encouraging and wholesome yes
except for in this case it's 69 in you
[Laughter]
all right tommy let's recap what
happened this episode it would be my
honor
what a ride morty makes a date with his
paramore jessica and escapes death by
crash landing in the ocean
disrupting a past treaty between rick
and his sexy sexy nemesis
mr nimbus mr nimbus controls the cops
which of course he does
not an ocean-bound creature rick sends
summer to find the shell that empowers
mr nimbus while he negotiates a new
treaty
mr nimbus propositions beth and jerry
for a threesome
and they are more than down
rick makes morty quickly age one in a
pocket dimension in which time moves
faster just like
narnia but morty's date with jessica
just can't ever get going because he
accidentally starts
a war with the hoovey race that spans
several
generations and i'm sorry that i'm
laughing through all this but this
episode was just so
damn funny oh my god jessica
finally gets sucked into the portal and
morty and rick get saved by mr nimbus
jessica's time into the dimension turned
her into a time
god not to be confused with a time lord
which is something only nerds care about
who is no longer
interested in morty rick gets arrested
but the real story went down in the
narnia dimension we're gonna break down
exactly what happened in that dimension
yeah uh before before we get to that if
you like our rick and morty coverage and
all the other content we make here at
new rockstars one of the best ways you
can support us is to check out our merch
at newrockstarsmerch.com
we have a line of exclusive loki
inspired merch based on the hit disney
plus show
we got buttons and hats five different
t-shirt designs off-screen producer zack
literally bought one for each of his
cousins those
lucky kids support this channel and get
yourself some cool swag you won't find
anywhere else by going to new york's
merch.com
but tommy what is our first question so
eric this is one that only you the
master of
all breakdowns can break down for me and
i knew as soon as i watched it i had to
hear your opinion what
is the narnia dimensions full historical
timeline
yes so much happens here and the
animators just
pack so much in there and we fly through
it
so it's worth kind of looking at each
cause there are several arcs that happen
in there and it's also well written
they actually crammed 14 generations of
story arcs in the background of this
episode
uh and the writer this episode this guy
jeff loveness someone you actually
know right tommy yes jeff is an old
friend of mine he used to work for jimmy
kimmel
uh and he wrote many of the uh star wars
sketches that i was lucky enough to be
in and he's also an improviser and a
very funny comedian
very funny guy also i think according to
you he grew up
with a pretty devout christian
upbringing yes he talks about that a lot
on twitter growing up and going to bible
camp
and yeah so and if you went to bible
camp or went to bible school you may
know the number 14 is very significant
because uh 14 generations separate
abraham to david
and then 14 separate david to the
carrying out to babylon and then from
there to the birth of christ and then
like the new testament
is like pretty proud of that like i
think it's the the gospel according to
matthew's just like
so we had 14 14 and 14. pretty cool huh
so like that number 14
every christmas mass is just shoved down
your throat
oh you're like okay numerology i guess
is important um
but i think it's interesting that the
number 14 shows up here because from the
perspective of this
race of people in the pocket dimension
morty is this kind of wrathful old
testament god
that ruined generation one who's kind of
an abraham figure
who has a horrible relationship with his
son who's an isaac figure
uh and then it spawns this whole history
that would lead to this society
wrapping itself around this demonic
figure
this deity uh first to overthrow him and
then ultimately to study him
and learn from him much like how our
society is pretty obsessed with the
deity whose whole
existence is debated you know by many
people in society
uh and to be clear we're not injecting
religion into this because rick himself
calls us out to begin the episode he
makes fun of c.s lewis's religious
parallels and chronicles of narnia
saying he's not a beaver who believes in
jesus christ
and then admits it is an arnie thing yes
yeah uh and then jessica by the end
evolves into
a time god so it's like they're rick and
morty
is at its core about like what happens
if a god had the personality of rick
you know so uh tommy i'm gonna quickly
break down each generation each of these
14 just so you can kind of get a sense
of the stories that happen within each
of these and how they're all connected
so we start with uh the farmers uh whovi
and bova hoovey is voiced by
jim gaffigan right and uh they're just
simple farmers living a peaceful life
she's
got a baby on the way they're watching
over these crates of wine that have just
sat there for decades undisturbed
uh from their point of view uh and then
hoovie just spends maybe a few moments
with morty and c137
uh to give him uh this advice and then
he leaves his home dimension behind for
several years in their time
so that brings us to generation two when
hoovy returns years later to find his
wife
dead and then his son japhet stabs him
out of anger over the abandonment
and then in his dying breasts hoovey
blames morty
as this child from the door
so then uh jump ahead to generation
three jfet
is like and i know i'm saying
generations where it's the same people
but it is like the different eras of
time so we can see how time has passed
and how they've like changed
things in the background and in this
case jfed has just let this farm go to
ruin
because it's just been driven by revenge
and rage and he's this jacked old man
yes i love morty's lie there why is
every old man jacked
um and in that fight he knocks out a
tooth which is important
uh so morty flees but then he goes you
know what whatever and he goes right
back in
but time again has passed we're in
generation four j that is now an elderly
man and you can see how his life has
changed
because that fight with morty you can
see since and he's
he's let go of it his farm is thriving
it's
uh it's sunny the crops are planted the
tree is now beautiful
um but he's just uh by himself he's got
this eye patch over his eyes
but morty beats the crap out of him uh
and then he's got these three sons
which you know that would be whovi and
bova's grandsons
um and then just to honor their father's
dying wish they
uh claim vigilance they swear this blood
oath uh and they dedicate their lives to
building this weaponized fortress in
order to attack morty if he were to ever
return
and notice that um the one in purple has
this weird-looking bird a bird that
comes back
because chef loveness is apparently
obsessed with birds
so now we come back generation five
where the three sons are now old men who
are
rulers over this kingdom and morty shows
up real quick
they release the the weapons and then
they think he's dead
uh and then you see the king and purple
get hugged by a little girl she comes
back
later uh okay so generation six uh so
now we're
years later and the three uh brothers
are even
older but they're continuing to force
their kingdom to be vigilant
at the expense of the kingdom's other
resources because you can see people are
kind of pissed off they're like this is
a myth
this is a legend it's not even gonna
happen you just made up the story
uh and then specifically one of the
other king's sons
the king in green he like accuses him of
the superstition
this would be hoovey's great grandson
the original jim gaffigan one
uh and then so that kid gets banished
and the sorcerer befriends them
and then we see a transition into
generation seven where that kid grows up
uh under the tutelage of the sorcerer
who like trains him in dark magic
he puts leeches on him yeah oh my god
and then you see during the this
training two of the three brothers have
passed away
leaving just his father left alive uh
and then
that sorcerer leads him back into a
rebellion
uh the kid kills his dad when the
sorcerer stabs him in the back
and then morty just returns and
everyone's like oh my god we were wrong
uh
morty blows up the castle but he leaves
he tosses behind carelessly a tech
gauntlet and he's found by now i think i
think i think i think this is a grown-up
version
of that young girl who hugged the purple
king yes and if that is
the case that is his daughter that would
make her cousins
to this uh rebellio this rebel and make
her hoovey's great-granddaughter
so we're still in the bloodline here i
think yes um
so then we see her lifted up generation
eight we come back
years later with this girl now on an
older woman is leading this
technologically advanced society
and she trains her son named adam who if
she is related that would make
who that would make him hoovey's
great-great-grandson we're still in the
bloodline
and he says he is a traveler yes which
is great
and he his mission is to assassinate
morty and they run these simulations in
this x-men style danger room which is
just great
um and we see how the society has
evolved with their iconography their
banners their flags to
be obsessed with this demonic version of
morty with horns and he's kind of this
devil figured them
um and in the background you can see
that she possesses what them would be
relics but they're samples of morty's
hair and that one knocked out tooth
that's kind of floating there so then we
go on to generation nine where adam is
now a hardened adult
uh and he wears this suit that is pumped
it looks like with the life force of
three others
they drain the other three into a belt
and then he pumps his suit full of that
uh so that he can live
and he thinks that he needs that so that
he can live in this other reality
and uh he goes in the portal he attacks
everybody but the jessica uses the
wine opener to cut the tether and it
causes him to chaotically de-age into a
baby agent
it's a lot like scott lang and avengers
end game when they're experimenting
uh and then adam just goes into this
weird trippy portal through time where
he meets this cosmic bird at the end of
time
on a dying tree he says like mother
that's just so beautiful and tragic yes
um
and then adam kind of basically flips
out of existence uh and then jessica
gets sucked back into the portal
um so then sometime later we find out
after this
generation 10 jessica is basically the
object of a
these bickering authorities that are
left over and they freeze jessica in
this crystalline state
uh and then behind them i love this you
can see murals depicting all the past
leaders so you have
uh bova who was erased from their
history
basically because they're pissed off at
him for abandoning them right uh
and then the son jay fett and then his
three sons also the bird
is still there and i think this bird is
definitely important in the society
yeah and then uh their son uh the son
who rebelled against them
and then adam and his mother uh so the
full bloodline there
generation 11 is throughout jessica's
montage she witnesses the society
falling into a brutal war
uh generation 12 jessica witnesses the
society invading artificial intelligence
big mistake
that leads to generation 13. the ais
have now slaughtered their creators
their skulls on pikes and they're
overseen by these cyberpunk birds
which i just have to think must be a
derivative the way like societies evolve
over time and just symbols change
meaning and the ais think like this was
important to us
uh and then they take that king's bird
the iconography
and then that becomes the bird overseers
of this ai
race absolutely uh and then that
brings us to the final generation we see
generation 14 where morty returns to
find what he thinks will be
his future self in this white void at
the end of time tuning into a tree
and then what they call a stripped-down
uh sundance sci-fi yes
which is what like that's annihilation
or yeah
what was the fountain maybe or oh the
yeah yeah the fountain yeah
oh so great um and uh because you know
the rick and morty writers are like
oh so basically just like one of our
subplots
in any given episode of rick and morty
if we were to just stretch that out to
90 minutes that could be a sundance
movie
right right yeah um but it's all a
simulation
uh and actually the reason i call this a
separate generation is the ai scientist
who talks to morty says that it has been
centuries
since the ai race has begun so that's at
least one generation but you know
dozens really and then this society ends
by getting wiped out by a flood
from nimbus which there's a noaa
parallel there
am i wrong no of course and for this
society just get wiped out by a simple
old testament
bible right that's a biblical disaster
for sure
it's full circle yeah uh and it ends up
spawning this new god
this time god of jessica in the universe
so
i don't know tommy am i wrong is this
the most like storytelling we have seen
in the background of a rick and morty i
mean it was just an insane
like the detail and yeah i don't
i can't think of another one i mean
obviously what was the
the train the um yeah the story train
406. tales from the citadel had four
different storylines yeah
but like spanning you know
centuries each of these things if you
look into them you can see like the game
of thrones style like
revenge plot the redemption plot right
the sorcerer being like doing doing the
classic
like evil mentor like people always like
whatever
reject others who think differently or
like just right right whatever the line
was but it was like oh my god this is so
perfect
because it's just this race of cow
humanoids
that are all yeah although the stakes
are so low it's just like
the guy went to help marty carry a heavy
case of wine
and it cost all of this
but i think it just speaks to the themes
of the episode of like jessica feeling
like she's
an object in the background but that
being more important than the storyline
that's happened like
all of this just takes place in the
blink of an eye to characters like rick
who are just having this debate with
nimbus
and what we think is gonna be the
episode this awkward interaction with
this sexy ocean king
uh is really the bee plot yeah this
other story involving this
narnia gate yeah which i think is such a
fun it reminded me a lot of the uh
did you watch the boys or not the boys
what am i thinking invincible on amazon
yes
um where they have a similar the flaxsen
yes that
isn't in a time-dilated dimension yes um
it's but the fact that they just explode
i think this rick and morty episode was
written before
uh maybe not the the invincible comics
but
no but yeah i imagine this was probably
written a couple of years ago right
yeah like clearly narnia is the the time
dilation of like what you think is a fun
storybook dimension right just gets so
dark everything gets so messed up oh my
god so good
uh this isn't the first time we've seen
like with a mic reverse
you know it's a similar kind of thing of
another pocket dimension taking place in
rick's world it just kind of puts
everything on a new scale
uh but i think it's fascinating just to
watch how much story can be unfolded in
this amount of pace
for sure it was almost like them running
victory laps in terms of story
structures
for sure for sure well we have some
other questions we want to ask about
what this means like why
poor morty getting his first kiss with
jessica that's why
he can't lock it down uh and whether
that will ever be the case uh first
thing some people helped us make this
episode
starting with our friends at bluetooth
bluechu has a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but
in chewable form and at a fraction of
the cost blue chew is an online
prescription service so no doctor's
office or pharmacy trips it ships right
to your door and discreet package you
sign up at bluetooth.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you receive
your prescription within days
their licensed medical providers work
with you to find the right ingredient in
strength and if you hate swallowing
pills good news blue chew is chewable
just like it says in the name so if you
could benefit from some extra confidence
when it's time to perform visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we've
got a special deal for our audience try
bluetooth free
when you use our promo code ricksplain
to check out just pay the five dollars
in shipping that's bluetooth.com promo
code ricksplain to receive your first
month free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
we thank bluechu for sponsoring this
show
this episode also is sponsored by
betterhelp is there something
interfering with your happiness and
preventing you from achieving your goals
well we've all been there at some point
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist start
communicating in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line or self-help it's
professional counseling done securely
online there's a broad range of
expertise available for clients
worldwide
you just log into your account anytime
and send a message to your counselor
you won't ever have to sit in a
comfortable waiting room or look for
parking
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free
to change counselors if needed it's more
affordable than traditional
offline counseling financial aid is
available betterhelp wants you to start
living a happier life today
visit betterhelp.com ricksplained that's
better h-e-l-p and join the over one
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help that they are
recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
special offer for the ricks blade
audience get 10 percent off your first
month at betterhelp.com all right tommy
back to the episode i
i want to ask you so jessica's a time
god do you think that's canon now do you
think morty could ever have a chance
with her might he have more of a chance
with her now that she's a time god
i i was thinking about this i wonder
i mean her last interaction was with
that creepy guy
kind of like uh cat calling her
right right she kind of snapped out of
it a little bit right like she kind of
didn't she like come to offer something
yeah exactly yeah so she's still a
person
you're right but it seemed like she's
the way she was speaking before with
this new like kind of
grandiose cadence and like you know like
i have seen
all now and like so i i guess i
my question is i think it's funnier if
she is
i mean in my opinion if she continues to
be a time god i have a feeling
my prediction with how jeff love this is
as a writer that he may want this
season to connect a little more you know
and maybe be a little
you know not just every episode is its
own thing i don't know
that may anger rick and morty fans that
just want it to be random funniness all
the time but uh
i think the tru i hope she is i guess my
answer is i hope she is and
will morty ever have a chance with her i
think he's gonna continue to have
near misses with her because that's like
the tortured you know we can't ever give
him
what he wants but he's gonna i think
he's gonna continue to go in
like they may need her as a time god to
fix something
and that may cause morty to continue to
try to make inroads but i
i don't i i think he'll always have a
chance and he'll never
succeed i like there was a lot of
griping online
about like morty not like after kissing
jessica
like why do we have another episode
where morty can't
end up with jessica it's like that's the
nature of the sitcom like you know
if you need to have characters
constantly get frustrated and i think
this is the funniest way yet
to see morty get frustrated by not
having a chance you basically turn her
into a god
you know yeah i think that was so funny
that whole monologue but
yeah i wonder if it's just like a lot of
us watching this show have been
romantically frustrated and
we just wanted that win for morty well
yeah
you know happy endings but that's not
what the show is about
yeah jessica's not like this is the most
fully fleshed out as a character she's
been
like morty has had uh plenty of pretty
disgusting sexual uh moments with other
characters
uh i'm just thinking of when he humped
that robot again again
yes uh but like but that's like
you know i i think morty can get wins in
plenty other ways that
are more satisfying to see rather than
he just scores his
school crush i want to ask tommy do you
think that narnia dimension is uh
connected to the other dimensions of the
rick and morty universe because the
portals are different right you have
yeah
swirling portals this one's like its own
weird portal yeah it's like almost like
a door like it's like
like he made like an interdimensional
doorway which i guess is what a portal
is but the portals are so like
iconically those green portals and rick
and morty so that
he kind of made this was like a um did
you see
uh in the modoc uh uh
cartoon that when he had the time
traveling thing it was like that
cut doors like that i don't know if
they're connected
i would assume if they were then one of
the plot points would have been the
superior
you know technology made contact with
other dimensions you know what i mean
there would have been like a we have
reached
like you know they would have done they
would have done a like a call back to
another
interdimensional being that rick and
morty have crossed
to you know like we found these people
but so i don't know i don't think it is
i think it's a standalone
little pocket dimension agreed yeah i
think that's
that's why they didn't make it its own
thing they wanted to be its own
little reality contained within like the
mic reverse and i think the idea is that
we're learning new rules every episode
of the show like for example we learned
that rick has a nemesis that we can't go
on the ocean you think back it's like i
guess we haven't really seen rick
on the water right you touched the ocean
yeah and it's only because it rebounded
off of a palm tree
right i know i know and it's like uh
i think we saw the in the rick lantis
mix-up season three episode seven right
where that all happened off-screen and i
think it was
going to be more of an episode it was a
relic of a cut episode according to jeff
loveness uh and we get a reference to
that now that maybe that
conflict is what led uh to the latest
stakes between
the two of them right so they have to
have but what i'm getting at is that
there are always new rules and i think
one new rule now is there are other ways
to do dimension hopping in the show
other than what we've seen yeah but
they're only contained within the
dimension that you're in
you know right uh so like but it also
says there may be other ways other that
there's like this time dilated one
there's a
the microverse battery rick has other
little pocket dimensions that serve
whatever
petty functional need that he requires
whether it's powering his ship or just
aging up wine or
other things which i think is real fun
the next question
kyle there's this mention of rick having
another assistant
named kyle who is kyle
i love how dismissive he was like don't
worry about that
and i love the fact that mr nimbus liked
the other guy but you but
here's the thing about the character of
mr nimbus is he may have only been
saying that just to be an [ __ ] the
morty you know what i mean oh sure
yeah that's possible you know like the
way horrible
bosses are always talking about their
great old employees like
the person who used to do this job but
uh i don't know who kyle is
i mean it's i hope we find out they're
never they
they i mean they rarely seem to drop
stuff like this without paying it off
so i don't know who do you think he is i
mean i think this is another implication
that
uh like it's not morty because we know
there's kind of a sacred connection
between rick and morty yeah like
morty has a inverse brain waves so it's
not like
rick would have that with kyle i just
think rick has an additional assistant
in some other timeline or some other uh
reality
that like was that he kept on the side
away from morty i mean it could
imply that in every reality there is a
coyote there's a kyle
just waiting and it's just gonna be like
you mentioned
uh having jo i've had jobs like working
in the tv industry
you do have these jobs where like your
boss flies through assistance
and i know you've worked on an animated
show tommy yes
my boss flew through assistance and
constantly told me about
kyle's uh yeah my first uh full-time job
i had i had assisted a kyle
and that kyle was replacing another kyle
and
all we heard about was the old kyle's
and how you're not as good as the other
kyle right
uh kyle is like the perfect name for
that so i'm hoping that like
kyle in this is kind of like uh in that
movie whiplash with jk simmons
yes you know how like miles teller plays
a drummer at that uh
conservatory like he brings in the other
crappier drummer
just to make him step up his gaze yes
like and that driver kind of sucks but
he's just like got that shitty and grin
on his face like
he's so nice too jake is so nice to him
he's like great right
i i hope we see more of kyle uh but the
last thing i want to ask about tommy uh
so season four ended with this big
cliffhanger of
finding out that that whole beth clone
arc from season three was legit and we
have space beth
who we think might be the original beth
who's like a rick like beth but also
having this
other bet we've had we think is clone
bath we don't know who
who is who rick doesn't even know who is
who but it was implied that like space
meth is going to be a thing on the show
now
but she did not show up no reference to
her in this episode now i know they
wrote a ton of these episodes
out ahead of time right not all of them
are going to connect to continuity wise
i assume we'll see space beth again
but what do you think happened to space
beth after
season four i wonder from a practical
standpoint if this just
episode didn't include her and she's
gonna be in the next step you know what
i mean
like i don't know what happened because
i i think
that it was made like clear that she was
going to be a part of the show
so i i don't know i guess i i don't have
a good answer for that i
i i i kind of just think it's like many
things like when we watch like
probably next week we'll see her like
yeah we know there's like a
voltron episode coming up we know
there's another vindicators episode
coming up
these are all plots that she could
conceivably tie into
but i think that is the nature of this
show like the canonicity is never really
the case and there was a theory that
every episode of rick and morty takes
place in a different dimension but we
know that's not true there is
certain amounts of continuity to
specific events that happen with this
particular rick and morty
we know from rick poach number nine that
their dimension got destroyed and
they've been
in this same dimension ever since then
there's been specific episodes that have
linked like
it's it's not chaotic uh like simpsons
like reset
right every episode but like that also
doesn't mean like you know the fact that
evil morty was established this isn't a
normal show where now evil morty's going
to be the
villain every episode she's going to
show up when the writers feel like
he's going to show up right right but
nimbus had this interesting line about
um
diane and until now we had thought
rick's whole uh history with his wife
diane might have just been a [ __ ]
story that he
told the federation just to get out of
that
um but now it's kind of implied that
it's confirmed his wife was
dianne right that something happened to
her so how
like how do you think nimbus knows diane
do you think this is a true story you
know it's kind of implied
that you know rick and nimbus not
implied it's stated directly we're like
friends first and then became
enemies so i wonder in my mind the fun
thing is
like that nimbus and rick were like
friends
or like in their 20s and like nimbus
knew diane well you know
and maybe maybe knew her really well
given mr nevis
uh yeah yeah insane sexual appetite
but uh yeah i think he definitely knew
about diane i think he
i think i think if diane is real and it
is a real story or
there's the chance that rick once used
diane
uh used his same like you know talking
about dan to make
mr nimbus take pity on him and spare him
in the situation where he maybe had to
jump on him
and now mr nimbus thinks that's some
sort of uh
uh negotiating currency with rick you
know like
yeah if i bring up diane that'll really
upset him and the truth is that diane is
just made up by rick
who knows rick is such a sick who knows
you know
yeah i don't think we'll ever uh i kind
of don't want them to ever
uh fully give us the story of diane i
kind of like it being this implied
piece of humanity from his past that yes
never true and it's a fun
tv trope that like they're kind of
making fun of of when shows reference a
thing and then they
and then i mean they do often pay it off
in the most unsatisfying way so it's
like never do it just never just have it
always be diane like what is that
yeah well we'll call it there for this
episode of rick splaned uh so the easter
egg breakdown of all the little details
that you might have missed this episode
will come out tomorrow
and tommy and i are gonna be back next
week to react to episode two of season
five
it is off to a great start i love this
show i didn't realize how much
i missed it and how densely packed it is
with jokes like it
puts all other tv shows to shame in that
regard it really does well
be sure to follow tommy at tommybechtold
on all social media you can follow me at
eavos
follow new rockstars subscribe to
ricksplained wherever you get your
podcast
thank you for watching and we'll close
with our favorite moment of the episode
oh [ __ ] he's real he's real i was wrong
i was so wrong god is real
[Music]
you